there are just three shopping days until
christmas and we all know last minute
larry
i can't i think that's very funny or
procrastinating patties so the window
for on-time delivery is all but closed
so plenty of shoppers are hitting the
stores risking a possible covet
infection as they search for presents
they also risk coming home with nada as
janet shamley in reports
many last minute shoppers are now
hearing these words out of stock there's
a lot of us explaining to people that
you know we don't have a lot of of what
they're you know might be looking for
this is houston's fundamentally toys
where supply chain issues mean many of
manager cliff moss's orders never
arrived there's a lot of things that
we're expecting that were expected two
months ago
we get emails daily about you know sorry
it's still on the water despite the
backlog the national retail federation
expects record growth predicting an 11
percent increase in holiday sales this
year all in the face of the omicron
variant does the national retail
federation not believe that the new
variant will have an impact on these
last few days there's a lot of
uncertainty
surrounding the new variant it's
impacting different parts of the country
in different ways with many online
retailers now unable to deliver in time
for christmas happy holidays
shoppers are looking to physical stores
even as omicron surgeons they're really
involved with the holiday season and not
thinking about the pandemic so much
anymore for those hoping to get it all
done before christmas long lines and the
fingers crossed attitude right now i'm
at usps and they really help me get my
last minute shopping sent out i'm
praying keeping my hopes up and keeping
the holiday spirit alive
shoppers told us they were mindful of
the increasing omicron risk as they
finished the holiday errands and gail we
saw considerably more mask wearing
inside and outside
that's a good thing janet you look like
a little christmas ornament in front of
those
jackets i like it fingers crossed
sometimes works thank you janet shamley
and thank you